179 mil 807 contagios en un solo día es
la cifra que hizo saltar las alarmas
este martes en francia es el mayor
número de contagios de kobe 19
registrado en europa en un plazo de 24
horas y uno de los más altos en todo el
mundo el gobierno ya anunció que la
vacunación será obligatoria para las
actividades de ocio desde el 15 de enero
y en parís no habrá celebraciones de fin
de año
en reino unido- también hubo récord de
contagios pero el gobierno descarta
aplicar nuevas restricciones españa
registró este martes una cifra inédita
de casos con cerca de 100.000 positivos
en ciudades como madrid la pelea es por
conseguir las pruebas gratuitas que se
entregan en las farmacias pues estas son
las que nos han llegado
una caja 2 4 6 8 10 20
y hay una cola esperando de 30 personas
la buena noticia en estos países de
europa son las tasas de hospitalización
que están lejos de la saturación vivida
en los momentos más críticos en eeuu son
miles los vuelos cancelados en parte por
la confusión que hay en torno a las
recomendaciones de las autoridades
sanitarias respecto al tránsito aéreo
nacional
la última directriz es la de acortar las
cuarentenas de ciudadanos a sintomáticos
de 10 a 5 días a pesar de la presencia
del nuevo linaje de kobe 19 en varios
países de américa latina méxico parece
no alarmarse pero la epidemia de covite
es sustancialmente la misma que podemos
ver si se presentara esa cuarta ola a
expensas de omicron podríamos ver una
gran cantidad de casos pero una
proporción mucho menor de
hospitalizaciones de lo que hemos tenido
en las zonas previas
méxico cuenta con un 55,8 por ciento de
su población con el esquema completo de
vacunación y el país nunca ha cerrado
sus fronteras y ha estado abierto al
turismo